these are the ones who didn't escape the
russian onslaught and they're all
civilians who'd been trapped in a
cluster of towns on the edge of the
capital where the fighting is
intensifying
they were bringing out casualties too
he's a pensioner with blood still
smeared on his face now finally in the
hands of his saviors
[Applause]
attacking civilians and non-competence
is a war crime
and the capital's top policeman is
already building a case
the police have already collected
evidence for judges at the international
criminal court in the hague they can
give their verdict about what russian
troops are doing here and how they've
been killing civilians we've already got
enough proof
white flags on vehicles plastered with
signs indicating there are children
inside aren't enough to guarantee safety
the towns they've just come from are
being fiercely fought over
and this route still drawing fire
see the black puff on the right one of
two mortars landing close to civilians
they're coming out under fire
with shelling
and firing going on behind them and many
of these people are terribly sick and
we've seen a number of them who are
injured
strangers suddenly become crucial
lifelines their bravery is the only
chance of escape
i'm from butcher and my neighbor called
me and told me the russian invaders are
here and they're looting all the houses
on the street this is the russian way
the russians are pushing closer to the
capital this footage just released by
the russian defense ministry they claim
shows troops landing at hostile airport
on the fringes of the capital
it's impossible to verify when this was
actually filmed but the russians claim
they've been in this area for about two
weeks
the capitals roads are being heavily
blockaded with defensive positions built
down most streets
but the real danger comes from russian
air attacks
where is
the trail of white smoke shows they miss
their target this time but the russian
jets will be back
so with shaking hands and uncertain
steps the terribly old and terribly
frail are pushing through their fear
somehow putting one step in front of the
other
coaxed forward an inch at a time by
younger hands and fitter bodies to make
this awful journey into yet more
uncertainty
they've been through so much already
it's a wonder they've got this far and
they're heading into a capital which
could also be bombarded
those who've escaped know it's just pure
fate
something went through the air and then
boom she tells us all the windows were
broken and the balcony fell down and the
tenth floor above us was just dust my
daughter came and said mama take your
stuff
until this i didn't want to leave my
town she says
she was in her home nowhere near any
military targets
yes she replies i'm okay thank you
she cannot believe what's happening
but right now they have to keep moving
the towns in the north west and east of
the capital are all being attacked with
kiev seen as the prize for the russians
so volunteers from all over the world
have been drawn to help
and when i saw it i i
honestly i booked a flight from
california and came here as fast as i
could it's uh
if this isn't the fight of democracy and
freedom against autocracy of our
generation i don't know what is
they're battling to hold on to every
inch of land but even if they keep the
russians out of the capital they know
they could be hit from the air
it's very strange to look out to europe
and union just say oh we don't want to
close the sky what
sorry don't be like
we're a small country to protect to
fight with russia with belarus so what
are you doing
it's it's not we protect not only our
country we protect all europe
they're bracing themselves for many more
civilian deaths for those here there are
far too many already
alex crawford sky news in urban on the
edge of kier
[Applause]